from laughter to outrage Dave Chappelle
is one of the most popular and
controversial comedians on the planet
but who is the man behind all the jokes
we'd wager that most 14 year olds have
no clue what they want to do with their
lives but that was the age Dave
Chappelle realized he wanted to become a
comedian he saw Bill Cosby on The Cosby
Show and was so inspired that he decided
to start writing jokes of his own while
attending the Duke Ellington School of
the Arts in Washington DC he studied
Theater Arts and began performing
stand-up comedy in the area his mom
would often have to accompany him to
clubs and bars since he was underage at
the time after graduating from high
school in 1991 he decided not to attend
college so he could move to New York
City and pursue a comedy career
full-time within months he was
performing in comedy clubs all over the
city he quickly made a name for himself
as people noticed his great sense of
humor personality and Charisma it
wouldn't be long before he took his
career to the next level by appearing in
TV shows and movies he looked in my ass
and I could see in his eyes that he
didn't remember meeting me the first
time Chappelle made his first major TV
appearance on Russell Simmons deaf
Comedy Jam each episode showcased
talented new Comedians and viewers
thought Chappelle was absolutely
hilarious the the show exposed him to a
much wider audience and helped him land
more opportunities to be on TV in 1995
he appeared in an episode of Home
Improvement as a member of The Tool Time
audience he didn't have much time on
screen but TV Executives were so
impressed that they gave him a leading
role in the spin-off series Buddies the
show centered around two friends trying
to run a video production company
unfortunately for Chappelle the show was
a flop and got canceled after only five
episodes while the series may have been
short-lived Chappelle's comedy career
was just getting started he went on to
appear in many more shows and movies
before eventually starting the immensely
popular Chappelle's Show in 2003 during
an interview with project casting in
2021 Chappelle said I love television
the fact that television ultimately made
me famous was very gratifying for me
in 1993 shortly after his first TV
appearance Chappelle put on a pair of
tights and took his career to a whole
new level he made his film debut as a
chew in Robin Hood Men in Tights it was
far from a serious role but higher-ups
could already tell they had a star on
their hands Chappelle's career kept
gaining momentum as he landed supporting
roles in several other movies such as
Ozzy and Undercover Blues Reggie in The
Nutty Professor and pinball in Conair in
1998 he co-wrote produced and starred in
the stoner comedy half-baked he played a
stoner who starts selling weed with his
friends to raise money to bail their
buddy out of jail although the movie has
become a cult classic it actually had
terrible reviews when it was first
released Neil Brennan who co-wrote the
film with Chappelle said that it
initially had a negative impact on both
of their careers because Hollywood
Executives didn't take them seriously
they drifted apart for a while then
several years later the pair co-wrote
Chappelle's Chef which became comedy
Central's top-rated program in 2005 and
launched Chappelle to Startup
Chappelle has a pretty eclectic group of
comedic influences he's heavily inspired
by Richard Pryor which makes a lot of
sense as Pryor would often joke about
race Chappelle is inspired by Eddie
Murphy as well having previously said
that Murphy was a major influence in why
he started doing comedy in the first
place but his biggest comedic influence
might be the Looney Tunes character Bugs
Bunny why
speaking to inside the actor Studio
Chappelle said it's weird if you watch a
lot of the stuff I do you can almost see
the influence in it he went on to praise
the voice actor for Bugs Bunny and
explained how the cartoons served as his
first major comedic inspiration in his
life now that you know Bugs Bunny
influenced Chappelle's style of Comedy
good luck on seeing it next time you
watch him perform
it's hard to believe that such a
hilarious comedian could get booed off
stage but Dave Chappelle has always had
a controversial style of comedy and his
jokes don't always sit right with every
audience shortly after he'd moved to New
York City to pursue his dream of
becoming a comedian he got the chance to
perform during amateur night at the
famous Apollo Theater in Harlem this was
a big opportunity to show off his
comedic potential so he tried his best
to impress the audience but they weren't
having it his jokes weren't landing and
he ended up bombing so hard that he was
booed off stage Chappelle later said the
incident actually encouraged him to
continue in Show Business instilling him
with Newfound confidence speaking on
inside the actor Studio he said that
night was liberating because I failed so
far beyond my wildest nightmares of
failing
Chappelle's religious Awakening all
started at a pizza shop in Washington DC
although the comedian stays quiet about
his religious beliefs for the most part
faith is a big part of his life chatting
to David Letterman he said I wanted to
have a meaningful life a spiritual life
not just what my hands can hold I felt
like I've always had this notion that
life should mean something when he was
17 years old he would go to a local
pizza shop where a lot of Muslim people
worked he was struck by how positive
they all seemed prompting him to ask
them about their beliefs he explained
how the owner of the shop answered his
questions and he found his explanations
interesting that led Chappelle to
convert to Islam when he was a teenager
and he hasn't looked back since he says
that being a Muslim has given his life
and career more meaning
Forrest Gump was such a great movie that
one would think any actor would jump at
the opportunity to be in it but Dave
Chappelle was offered the role of Bubba
and turned it down he wasn't interested
in the role because he thought it
perpetuated demeaning stereotypes about
black men in the movie Bubba had a
learning disability but was slightly
more intelligent than Forest however
Chappelle claims he read an earlier
version of the script in which Bubba was
even more dimwitted than Forest which
didn't appeal to him at all Chappelle
later regretted turning down the role
since the movie was so successful in
1997 he starred in a short parody of the
film called bowl of pork starring as an
unintelligent man who realizes that life
is just a bowl of pork
ow damn to this day Chappelle's Show is
one of Chappelle's most memorable
projects and for good reason he wasn't
afraid to take on big issues like race
and social stereotypes in the
groundbreaking sketch comedy series it
was a huge hit and at one point Comedy
Central offered him 50 million dollars
to keep making it instead in 2005
Chappelle shocked everyone when he
abruptly left the show during production
of the third season Chappelle had been
filming a skit about pixies that
embodied different races and liked the
skit but a crew member laughed at a
moment that made him wonder if he was
reinforcing racial stereotypes rather
than making fun of them speaking to
David Letterman Chappelle said the
sketch wasn't that bad it's actually
funny it was a pixie it was me dressed
in blackface who'd pop up any time a
person felt the Pains of racism which is
a tough trick to pull off it's not a bad
sketch but hearing the wrong laugh while
you're dressed that way it makes you
feel shame he said that wasn't the only
reason he left but it did influence his
decision he had already been feeling
overwhelmed pressured by the network and
unhappy with the direction the show was
going the incident was just the straw
that broke the camel's back
after leaving his show Chappelle took
things a step further and left the
entire country he visited South Africa
for a while and when he returned to the
United States he started Living a more
reclusive lifestyle he stepped away from
the spotlight moved to Yellow Springs
Ohio and made much fewer public
appearances than before he did release
the documentary Dave Chappelle's block
party in 2006 but other than that he
mostly kept to himself in 2013 fans were
happily surprised to see Chappelle at
The Comedy Cellar in New York City
Comedian Chris Rock joined him on stage
and the two talked about possibly
touring together shortly afterward
Chappelle made a formal return to
stand-up comedy and started touring the
country did he miss his fans or did he
just need more money fans didn't know
and they didn't really care because the
bottom line was Chappelle was back they
welcomed him with open arms and he went
on to appear in many more movies and
shows including A Star is Born and
Saturday Night Live in 2016 he also
reportedly signed a deal with streaming
giant Netflix earning 60 million dollars
in return for three comedy specials I
was like
the Laugh Factory has an endurance
record for the comedian who can perform
stand-up for the longest amount of time
Richard Pryor set the record by
performing for two hours and 40 minutes
back in 1980 then Dane Cook set a new
record for three hours and 50 minutes in
2009 not long afterward Chappelle broke
that record with the performance lasting
six hours and seven minutes later that
year he topped his own record by
cracking jokes for 6 hours and 12
minutes Laugh Factory owner Janie Masada
told HuffPost that Chappelle broke his
own record since he found out Dane Cook
had his eyes set on less than a month
later cook took the stage again and set
a new record by telling jokes for a
whopping seven hours the set went on for
so long that he sent out food to the
audience salt and pepper peanut butter
and jelly Dave Chappelle and controversy
some things just go together throughout
his entire career Chappelle has faced
controversy for pushing the limits of
Comedy it is contributed to his massive
success but it has also gotten him in
hot water especially with the lgbtq plus
Community they criticized him for being
transphobic in his home 2021 Netflix
special the closer he spent a lot of
time joking about transgender people
after the special was released things
got so heated that a group of Netflix
employees staged a walkout at
headquarters to advocate for transgender
rights Netflix stood by Chappelle and
said it would not censor artists as for
Chappelle he doubled down on his beliefs
towards transgender people in his 2022
special what's in a name he addressed
the backlash he faced saying the more
you say I can't say something the more
urgent it is for me to say it and it has
nothing to do with what you're saying I
can't say it has everything to do with
my right my freedom of artistic
expression that is valuable to me
nothing was off limits in Chappelle's
Show so the comedian once poked fun at
Prince in one of the sketches he
impersonated the legendary musician and
destroyed Charlie Murphy at a game of
basketball all while looking absolutely
fabulous Prince responded by putting a
photo of Chappelle impersonating him on
the cover of his 2013 single breakfast
can wait in the photo Chappelle is
wearing an elaborately ruffled blouse
like Prince did in Purple Rain era and
holding a plate of pancakes in an
interview with Jimmy Fallon Chappelle
said the following about it that's a
prince Judo move right there you make
fun of prince in a sketch and he'll just
use you in his album cover what am I
going to do sue him for using a picture
of me dressed up like him as Checkmate
right there Chappelle is known for his
sense of humor but in this case it looks
like Prince got the last laugh
[Music]